Russia and Ukraine have exchanged
hundreds of prisoners of War and the
biggest swap since the War Began seven
months ago the detainees have been freed
include UK U.S and Moroccan citizens as
well as Commandos from Ukraine's azov
Battalion which held out against a
prolonged rotten Siege in Mario Paul in
return keeps set free oligarch Victor
medvichok he's an ally of Vladimir Putin
and he's facing charges of treason and
54 Russian prisoners
congratulations on your return our guys
are heroes it's good to see everyone
it's nice after all the time we've been
on the phone we're proud of you what
you've done for our nation proud of each
and every one of you and I'm very glad
that the team got you out of Russia I'm
glad we made the first step you are safe
in Turkey the second step is of course
to get you home
in a separate deal negotiated by Saudi
Arabia 10 foreigners who fought for
Ukraine have been freed by Russia and
sent to Riyadh among them is Aiden Aslan
the British citizens sentenced to death
by moscow-backed separatists
okay for more on this let's speak to
Gabriel Elizondo he's joining us live
now from Kiev how are the ukrainians
reacting to this deal Gabe
in a word ecstatic this is a big victory
for most ukrainians who wake up this
morning getting this news and they're
thrilled quite frankly and the reason is
is because these soldiers that were
released by the Russians in this
prisoner swap any soldiers would have
been considered a victory for ukrainians
but this is particularly Bittersweet for
them if you will use that terminology
because of who they were more than the
majority of these 215 prisoners that
were released Were Soldiers as we
mentioned from the azov regiment that
held out for weeks and weeks at the azos
doll steel plant in mariupo they are
considered and have been considered for
many months now national heroes for what
many ukrainians consider their
incredible bravery during the early and
middle stages of this war and you can
see it all over the city in fact right
behind me you can actually see this is
the city hall all building here in Kiev
and they've had this huge Banner that's
been on the front of this building for
many months now reminding ukrainians
every day on how they wanted to free
these uh soldiers from this regiment so
this is considered a very big day for
the ukrainians they feel that this is a
huge Victory because of these soldiers
that were now released and Gabriel we
were talking about the the Kiev has also
freed the oligarch Victor Medford who is
this the high ranking politician that
Ukraine's releasing to Russia foreign
yeah he's a former politician here in
Ukraine he was released he has an
interesting sort of a shadowy history
here in Ukraine he's an oligarch he's 58
years old and he's been part of the
pro-russia opposition but not only that
he is very close on a professional and
personal level to Vladimir Putin in fact
their extended family members if you
will because uh uh medvichuk's a child
that he has Vladimir Putin is the
Godfather to his child so they go back
many years and he's uh he was in the
opening stages of this war he was
arrested by the ukrainians on treason
charges and held under house arrest he
fled house arrest and then was re
re-arrested by the ukrainians and so he
is a figure that now the ukrainians will
be turning over as part of this deal to
the Russians Gabriel thank you very much
indeed get Alexander bringing us up to
date from Kiev